certainly you saw something with this
team and more importantly with just the
influence of basketball there that led
you back there yeah Larry and Jeremy the
leadership of our league have done such
an amazing job group doesn't it he
refuses to wear a mask right he won't
wear a mask I I don't I don't know what
his deal is but as long as it keeps
playing well we'll let him get away with
it Oh basically inhabited by friends in
be a place that have had a chance to
make it beautiful the Sun side eight
smothers it on the glass and I thought
he was gonna break the backboard smash
smash we call them it and the payoff
pass inside eight
say that's a block and I think is really
no jumped up into the ticket it's
credible from beyond the arc
that's beautiful
the quick police just beautifully put
the ball above his head who's gonna take
it already got a double-double at 13 and
10 look at the footwork not the ball
above is it took the little guy away and
Kevin bras well any breakers were so
incredibly appreciative of it and spoke
fluently and says not surprisingly just
speaks to the character of Igor
Kokoschka Boris double figures that make
8 is 13 and a reason 13 there's the big
man off the elbow inside just turn and
brings the hammer bleeding but they
can't get the ball up this quick
attention out stadiums for our
professional matches look out
[Applause]
were teammates give teammates don't give
him a hard time though he's blocked
himself there but at least he got it
back in Finnish Aaron banks they really
are contributors yes how involve are
they you all use them
to try to get their input maybe come
back right at best as if again
tells you not only is he interested
anything